plus aucun train de part de la gare de
cravates or sq pour évacuer les civils
de la région depuis une frappe russie a
fauché des dizaines de vies cette
attaque a provoqué l'exode de la
majorité de la population de la ville
alors certains tentent de partir par
d'autres moyens
on est allé à cela viennent pour essayer
de prendre le train parce qu'à cramatte
or c'était impossible mais là bas
c'était pareil alors on est revenu pour
essayer de trouver n'importe quel moyen
de transport
donc bien des endroits la ville
ressemble à une cité fantôme entre les
bâtiments détruits et les fenêtres
barricadées
[Applaudissements]
mais sirène hurle sans cesse et une
image à kloten une joggeuse que rien ne
semble perturber
on me dit de partir mais j'étais resté
en 2014 et aujourd'hui nos combattants
sont mieux organisés
j'aime ma ville et je veux qu'elle reste
entière
[Musique]
quelques commerces font de la résistance
je nourris les gens les policiers les
soldats tout est fermé dans la ville on
ne peut pas acheter à manger c'est pour
ça que je reste ouvert les gens sont
très reconnaissants
parmi ceux qui sont restés certains
n'avaient nulle part où aller et puis il
ya ceux qui sont persuadés que l'ukraine
vaquera
dans ce local depuis la première guerre
du dombass en 2014 des volontaires
fabrique des filets de camouflage pour
les véhicules et les soldats et ici on
n'a pas l'air impressionné par vladimir
poutine
qui devrait avoir peur de ce nom non il
ne m'a jamais fait peur grâce à nos
enfants nous avons le gaz d'électricité
une vie normale c'est pour cela que nous
devons les aider nous devons les
protéger avec notre camouflage s'il
permet de sauver un seul bien nous
serons
cet optimisme n'est pas partagé par tous
et ils sont encore nombreux à vouloir
quitter cravate or sq dans une ville
vidée des trois quarts de sa population
les derniers habitants attendent avec
anxiété une offensive russe dont on ne
cesse de répéter qu'elle passera par
cravate or sq